okay
welcome back this will be the final
thought of the fine grain University
thread
um
Ness for click problems mostly click on
detection and create listing so a
k-click is a set of keywordsies where
there's an edge between every pair
overseas
and it is a k click detection funding is
a special case of subgraph detection
funding and
here we usually have a kind of large
graph as input such as the graph on the
left then we also we're also given a
pattern which is typically smaller such
as this five click on the right
and the subgraph detection problem asks
us to answer whether the large graph
contains a pattern as a copy and the
subgraph finding problem
in the sub crowdfunding version Excel
the copy we also have to Output this
copy
and click of course is the densest graph
cable text
uh advances cable text graph and also we
can formally show that if we can detect
a k click in some amount of time and
then we can also detect any other cable
tax graph in roughly the same amount of
time so in this distance K click
detection is the hardest problem for
keynote graphs
and the notion of clicks are
started at least as early as the 1940s
in the context of social network
cohesiveness
and it can be used to
capture social relationships such as
friendships
and dense graph detections also have
many applications in other areas such as
data mining finance and detecting us
then subgraph can be useful for finding
communities in networks and so on
so click funding is a important problem
and in this talk I will first briefly
talk about finding K clicks and the main
focus of the token will about will be
about listing clicks and most
specifically will be about
um listing triangles
so here's a reminder of the definition
in Click detection we are giving a graph
and we have to determine whether the
graph G has a click of says K and in the
click funding version we also have to
return Okay click of this one copy
and uh
click is actually one of the
first problems to be known to be MP
complete and if one case part of the
input so unless P equals MP there's no
efficient algorithm for K click in the
case when kids are part of the input so
we will focus on the case where K is
fixed that case affect constant that is
independent of n
and The Brute Force algorithm for K
click runs into the K time basically we
just enumerate OK tools or vertices and
check whether they form a k click
um so the question is whether we can
find a k click much faster than this
into a brute first time
and under the exponential time
hypothesis is known that there's no into
the little okay time algorithm for K
click finding
and the exponential time hypothesis says
that no algorithm cancel Consulting
upset on variables in time 2 to the
little of n so it is a weaker version of
the strong exponential time hypothesis
we saw earlier in earlier talks and in
strong exponential time hypothesis we
are basically assuming that CF set
requires to to the earn minus little o
of end time and here is assume the
running time is much lower so this
hypothesis is weaker and more likely to
be true
so under exponential time hypothesis the
best we can hope for is to find a
constant Alpha so that K click finding
can be solved in into the alpha K time
hopefully for some Alpha very small and
less than one
and
so indeed there is a better algorithm
that can give some Alpha less than one
using faster matrix multiplication
and we will use Omega to denote the
exponent so that two and match this can
be multiplied into the Omega time which
is known to be less than 2.372
and using fast matrix multiplication K
click finding can be solved in
to the K minus 3 minus Omega times K
over 3 float 10. and for Simplicity
throughout this talk we will mix the
assumption that Omega is 2
and while Omega 2 this around time can
be simplified to enter the K minus Q
lesson float
and for a three click or triangle
this runtime is into Omega and the
algorithm is basically the following
were given the adjacency Matrix a of the
input graph and we're using fast matrix
multiplication to compute a squared
then the uv's entry of a squared will
will count the number of two passes from
U to V and then we basically enumerate
Opals of vertices u and v and track
whether there's an edge between u and v
and whether the other two paths from U
to B
and so the bottleneck of this algorithm
is to compute a square so the running
time is into Omega
for larger K the idea is basically to
First reduce quickly funding to Triangle
finding and then run this into Omega
triangle finding algorithm
for instance 1K is six
we first group all pairs of vertices in
the input graph as a super vertex and
then between every pair of two super
vertices which corresponds to four
vertices in the original graph we will
add an edge if it has a four click in
the original graph
then for every triple of supervises
there is a triangle if and only the
corresponding six vertices in the
original graph form a sixth click so now
the problem becomes finding triangles in
this new graph whose number of vertices
is N squared which can be solved in
until 2 Omega time
and more generally generally when K is
divisible by 3 and omega-2 the running
time is into the 2K over three in one
case nothing divisible by three
the formula is slightly more complicated
because just because the graph we
created in the reduction will be
unbalanced
foreign
so in the previous slide you said we get
this little okay under the explanation
time hypothesis if we assume the strong
exponential time hypothesis can we get a
better bound on that quantity or not
um
yeah concrete constant on this joints
what is the best runtime
oh yeah the best one time for coming so
algorithms basically into it
how to pull out improvements
the algorithm you just described
so you you you're looking for a sixth
leak so what you do you partition the
graph into how many parts
it's not partition it's like picking
every pale versus and create a new
vertex in a new graph so the new graph
will have 10 square vertices and
original graph only has 10 vertices okay
yeah and in the new graph each ads will
encode
whether like uh each address between two
superverses in the new graph which will
correspond to four old vertices all
right so we add an edge if among these
all for all the vertices there's a four
click
a triangle in the new graph will be a
sixth peak in the order
so I I got it I don't know
oh
yeah uh yeah actually for constant K
finding a detection actually more or
less the same problem
in roughly the same amount of time
but uh when we say k click you can think
it has a cake binding
thank you
yeah so that's it for Cricket funding
and now I will switch to click listing
and now the problem is gamma graph G we
want to list all of its K clicks
in the worst case the graph itself can
be a node complete graph and in that
case it will have until the k k clicks
and The Brute Force into k-time
algorithm can also be used to list all
the key clicks so it seems that this
into the K running time is optimal in
this sense
um but in many cases the number of pay
clicks will be much smaller than into a
k and the question is in that case
whether we can list turkey clicks faster
than this Brute Force running time
and in the extreme case when G only has
1K click then the previous K click
finding algorithm which finds one key
click is can already list all the key
clicks because we only have 1K click in
the graph and which has run in time
until 2K over three under this
assumptions so
when a number of key clicks is smaller
it's indeed possible to get a faster
algorithm
and in general we can ask what if Geo
has TK clicks for some G between for
some T between one and two okay
and and the tax graph can have at most
unsquare address but also in many cases
the number of address in the graph will
be smaller than n square and in that
case
we should denote the number of edges in
the graph I am and M will actually be
the input size of the of the problem or
the database size
so at running time in terms of M will
also it's also very natural and
interesting
so suppose suppose the graph G has M
address it's known that g can have at
most n to the K over 2 K clicks
and we can also list all these K Clicks
in um to the Q over two time
similar to the
dance case this running time is optimal
when the number of K clicks is actually
m to the K over two but in many cases
there are a few key Clicks in the graph
and when the number of K clicks is only
one
that's indeed a faster Okay click
funding algorithm on the right on the
left it's a reminder of the running time
in terms of n which is enter CK where CK
is K minus kill battery float
and on the right the running time
actually depends on the CK so the K
click running time in terms of M is m to
the core over 2 for K greater than three
k equals three
okay so yeah so this is a picture we
talked about the right hand side which
are like the Brute Force algorithms are
optimal and the left hand side which are
the click signing algorithms
okay and then
okay one kid becomes oh I see but in
general when kids dependent on the
problem is uh MP complete but leaving
some special cases
is a
say like
one case n minus C
yeah
I think it becomes like vertex cover
it becomes a Vertex cover
so one case like MRC the there's also
Point number
okay
so next I will focus on triangle listing
and first I will show you how to list
all triangles in m to the 1.5 ton I
think we also saw this in Monday's
lectures but our uh so this algorithm in
terms purely in terms of the language of
graph algorithms and then I will show
how to slightly modify this algorithm to
get um m2fosters running time so I can
find one time
so this algorithm will
first classify or vertices based on
their degrees and we'll call any vertex
low degree if it has degree at most D
and we'll call vertex High degree if it
has degree greater than d
and forever at UV where U has low degree
in the graph will list all other
neighbors V Prime of U and then track
whether VV Prime is an edge and if so
as we can see because V and V Prime are
both neighbors of U and we check what we
check that there's an edge between V and
V Prime we can conclude that UV V Prime
is indeed a triangle
and the running time for a first step
because for each Edge we are enumerating
uh at most the other neighbors because
we make sure that U is a low degree will
attacks so the runtime for the first
step is M times d
and after the first step if there's some
triangle in the graph that hasn't been
listed then we know that all three
vertices of the triangle must all have
high degree so at this point we can
remove all the low degree worksheets
from the graph
and
because the sum of degrees of the
vertices uh is 2m so the number of high
degree vertices can be at most 2m over d
then we just try all triples of high
degree with this
and
therefore the running time of this
algorithm is M times D plus M over D
cubed by 13d to be square root M the
runtime becomes M to 1.5
probably more
but including another language
[Music]
so
now let me show how to slightly modify
this algorithm to get a faster algorithm
that can find one triangle so the basic
idea is to replace the brute full step
by fast matrix multiplication
so here we are doing the same low degree
High degree classification of all the
vertices and for the for a review where
you have low degree we also do the same
thing
and after this first step if no triangle
is found that means any triangle in the
graph has three High degree vertices so
now we can assume the graph has at most
qm over D versus
and at this point we run fast matrix
multiplication based algorithm to find a
triangle in this graph and we know in a
graph with capital N vertices we can
find the triangle in capital N to the
Omega tan for running time for the
second step now is M over D to the Omega
over or running time this is this
13d to be m to the Omega minus 1 over
Omega plus 1
the running time is m to the 2 Omega
over Omega plus 1 which is m to the four
thirds one Omega is two
can you go backwards right so when Omega
is not two yeah that's not true it's a
two Omega over Omega Plus
that's 1.41 with the current example 1.4
okay so indeed one t is between uh for
other values of T there's indeed a great
algorithm that has a
so
the running time can be expressed in two
ways either in terms of earn or in terms
of M in terms of and the runtime is n
square plus n times t to the two thirds
so this unsquare part because in a dense
graph we actually need to read and
square input address so this n Square
part is actually inevitable in that
sense
and the second runtime is in terms of M
which is m to the forces plus M times t
to the one third
and this M24 series time is the same as
the running time to find just one
triangle so if we cannot improve the
running time to find one triangle this
M2 forces part is also inevitable
and
in fact we can
so if Omega is not too experience four
by three becomes two Omega Omega plus
one that's correct
the second part
yes
I'm not very sure that the authors know
that it's a function of Omega okay this
amount is crazy
Square comes into Omega
yeah
yeah and we can actually show this uh
for any time is optimal
um hypothesis
so at least one t equals n this one this
upper bound is optimal on the threesome
hypothesis
and later this is generalized to other
values values of t as well so
now that we know under threesome
hypothesis as n times t to the one third
time is easier to this T Channel a match
graph and N times t to the two thirds
time is needed to this T triangles in a
node graph so red parts are also if
Omega is not to these results are not
affected yes these results the lower
bounds do not depend on Omega
they match the upper bound uh in the
ideal case of Omega 2.
thank you
and here are the results are on the
threesome hypothesis but later it's
strengthened to a even more believable
hypothesis which I'll talk about later
and I will actually show the proof for
this result for the special case of T
equals m
and this more believable hypothesis is
uh this exact triangle hypothesis which
I believe we also briefly mentioned
yesterday
and in the exact jungle problem we are
given a note weighted graph
and the task is to detect whether it has
a triangle whose three AdWords sum up to
zero and we assume all the attributes
are integers bonded by polynomial
the exact triangle hypothesis says that
to solve the exact triangle problem we
essentially need mq time which is the
blue first time
why is it more believable than through
some hypothesis
it's because that we can reduce both
threesome and apsp to exact triangle
and this implies that as long as one of
the threesome hypothesis or the apsp
hypothesis hold then the exact triangle
hypothesis will hold
so it's possible that the threesome
hypothesis fails but the apisp of us
they still holds in the case exact
triangle hypothesis will still hold
and so it's desirable to design
reductions from exact triangle because
if you know some problems had under the
exact strangle hypothesis you
automatically get that it is hard on the
two of the three Central hypothesis in
Franklin complexity
and there are in fact also problems
known to be had under all three of these
Central hypothesis we have the matching
triangle problem and a triangle
collection problem
and design reductions from them will
give you a very believable lower bounds
that hold under any of the three
capacities
but in today's talk I will only focus on
exact triangle
and
recall that the goal is to show that
listing um triangles in a graph is hard
and the overall structure of the proof
is following will reduce one exact
triangle instance to all an instance of
Django listing
and in each of these instances we will
have nodes and the max degree of each of
the instance will be square root to n so
the number of address in each instance
will be exposed into 1.5
and then assume for the sake of
contradiction that if they are then
faster them to the Foster stem algorithm
for each instance then we will get a
faster than Cube algorithm for example
so this uh of course also need that
reduction itself is efficient but uh
let's see we'll see that the reduction
itself is very it's certainly sub cubic
and in fact our first show a slight
variant of the triangle listing problem
so here at first we'll show that listing
o1 triangles for each Edge is hard
so overall we still list om triangles
but now
previously it's okay to list many many
triangles for some for some address but
no triangles or some other address but
now we first require that we list all
one triangles for charge you can think
of this o1 as something like 100 and
then if some Edge is in at most 100
triangles then we need to list all of
them and if it's in more than 100
triangles it's okay to list any subset
of 100 travels
and we can assume the input graph for
exact changes and
you can do this by just copy copying the
graph three times and between every pair
of copies we add back of the original
address with the original Edge weights
and this Tango in the odd graph will be
uh we're still presenting this new graph
actually six times
and we also assume the AdWords are from
some Finance field FP for some
sufficient to a large Prime p
you can just take this P to be um for
instance three times greater than the
Max absolute value of the import address
and doing this and and mode all the
attributes by P and doing this will now
change the set of zero weight triangles
in the input graph
so
uh
we will first split the final field FP
to square root and contiguous ranges L1
L2 up to L Square to n and each range
will have size roughly p over Square 10.
and the basic idea is to enumerate
triples of these ranges LJ LK and
only considers triangle only considered
triangles ABC such that the width of a B
is in aoi the weight of BC is in L J and
the weight of C as in AOK
and after we enumerate all possible
tables of ijk and like any triangle will
be included in one of these enumeration
and one of the key observations that if
it's not possible to take one number
from each range that can sum up to zero
then we do not need to consider this
triple of Rangers
so we only need to consider LJ okay okay
if zero is in the sum set
of LG okay Samsung just means
the sumset of two sets is just a set
that can be formed by taking a sum of
one number from the first set and one
number from the second set
and because of this observation we only
need to enumerate all in such tuples
to see this we can just see like the
sumset of L and LJ because L and LJ
themselves are two Rangers there are
some sets will also be a range but so
probably slightly larger size and in
order for zero to be included in UI plus
LJ plus LK negative AOK need to
intersect with l i plus l j
because but uh now aoi past LJ is a
range of similar size and we split the
whole final field to square turn ranges
there will be only there will only be
016 okay so that's not okay intercept
with L plus l j
and
some in difficulty is that the AdWords
are not evenly distributed
remember
that the goal is to create all instances
of triangle listing so that each
instance have roughly until 1.5 address
but if the attributes are not evenly
distributed then it's possible that for
some triple of renders will include more
address but for some other triples we
are we include few address that's not a
reliable and also in the Triangle
listing instances we'll actually drop
all the edge weights
triangles in the graph so it's possible
that the algorithm keeps listing
triangles
that are actually not exact triangles in
the original instance
and in the if the edge weights are worst
case and it's possible that we are
keeping listing on false positives and
will never reach the actual zero weight
triangle
so to resolve this we
or randomize the weights in the
following way
we'll pick random element X from FP and
for every vertex U
will pick a random element y u and then
we'll create the new weights W Prime in
the following way
and so even though the graph itself is
not directed in this step it's helpful
to sync to direct address from a to c
from C to B and from B to a
and for an edge directing from some
vertex 0 to some vertex V the new weight
will be x times times its odd weight
minus y u and plus y v
right so here an edge from a to c has
new weight x times
W AC minus y y a plus y c okay because
we are directing the address in this
clockwise way
the weight the new weight of a triangle
will be x times its order weight
and because we are in a final field and
if x is non-zero then the set of silver
triangles in the graph will not change
and the probability that x is 0 is very
small so it can more or less ignore that
case
foreign
between part A and part C we include
included only if it's in the range LK
for address between part A and B we
included if it's in range aoi for part
between for address between B and C we
include it if it's in range LJ
and because our goal is to get a graph
whose Max degrees is order of square
turn we also have to delete all the
vertices whose degree is larger
so here we create a graph G Prime ijk
which is just G Prime which is just grjk
but we will remove overseas whose
degrees are larger than 200 square root
and plus 200.
and finally at once we have this G Prime
igk we will run the triangle listing
algorithm to list all one triangle for
each Edge and for each listed triangle
we'll actually check in the original
graph whether it has zero it
okay so because
G Prime r3k do not have width anymore
any questions
so
so that's a reduction so now let me show
you uh why it is cracked
basically two bad cases
the first one is that we can potentially
delete a zero wave triangle
and because by the way we create the
graph g i j k it's always guaranteed
that one exact one zero eight triangle
will be included in one of the graphs
grjk
however in G Prime at UK we are removing
some vertices with large degree so
a test step we can potentially delete a
zero triangle
please remind us what is
over the probability is uh
is from the random choices of X and Y
'all
so and yeah and we'll show that this
will not happen with
so black ADC be any of the silver candle
in the infograph
and for any B Plant that's not d uh the
new weight w prime a b Prime by
definition is x times it's all the
weight
minus y b prime plus y a
so notice that this YB Prime is a fresh
random variable it's a completely
independent with the fact that ABC is in
the graph to IDK
so the new weight w prime a b Prime is
completely random so the probability
that it's in the range aoj is roughly
one over Square return
because we have squared and ranges of
roughly the same size
therefore by Summit over order B Prime
that expected the expected number of
neighbors of vertex a in Part B is at
most square root n plus one
and this question
comes from the sum of ODSP primes and
this plus one comes from the vertex B
itself
and similarly the actual number of
numbers of a in part C can also be upper
bounded by square root n plus one
so the expected degree of a is 2 times
square root n Plus 2.
most
and recall that would delete our vertex
a only if its degree is greater than 200
times greater than plus 200 which is 100
times more than this expectation and by
markov's inequality this uh this will
happen with probability less than 0.01
and we can do the same analysis for
vertex B and C and therefore we will not
delete any of ABC with probability
greater than 0.97
when taking the probabilities since the
definition of g i j k involves the the
random choice of weights
when then what does it mean to consider
competency over that
um we'll consider is the probability
that uh W prime a b Prime is in the same
range as wab just about the statement of
the claim that is the claim for each ijk
if it has a simple triangle then with
probability yeah
yeah this the statement is not very
formal but basically we want to say that
for each fixed they will triangle ADC
yeah it's going to be in some geography
which depends on the Range
but uh we will not delete it with
properly 0.79
and as you can see in this analysis we
like where is the fact that why we plan
is completely independent of the fact
that ABC is interacted
so it's it's the claim that every
triangle has a large probability of not
being removed to set more formulates
ABC in the graph we will not delete it
when we are creating this um
so the second about case is the phone
um so it's possible that uh
ABC still exists in gene Prime ijk but
there are also many other triangles
exist in g-crime objects involving
involving architect
so listing o1 triangles for Hab does not
necessarily list this zero with triangle
ADC it can list all these other
triangles that do not have zeroids these
are the false positives
we only need to show only need to show
that this case happens with a small
probability
and so let's see plan their vertex so
that ABC Prime is not a zero triangle
and that spawns the probabilities that
ABC Prime is in the graph GI okay
so
one for ABC prompt to be in the same
subgraph grjk with ABC
we must have that um
the difference we must have that W Prime
AC and W Prime AC Prime
must be in the same range and in order
for them to be in the same Branch their
differences must be between active po
West skirt and possible term because
this is roughly the size of each range
and the same thing holds for w Prime BC
minus W Prime BC Prime
with some calculation we can show that
these two values are actually
independent uniform random variables
from FP so the probability that both of
these containment happen is at most
order of well button
so the extraction number of such C Prime
is only order one
and as long as we are listing uh more
than 100 times this expectation
uh
and because in that case the number of
such C Prime the probability that the
number of C Prime actually reaches 100
times its expectation is only 0.01 and
if we are as long as we are listing more
than that we will reach the actual C
with uh with probability 0.99
any questions that concludes this
prove to the listing o1 triangles for a
charge case
actually it can we zoomberg a little bit
uh
I thought the segment that we were
trying to move was not really realistic
um
yeah I think the the conditional lower
bound
um
could you please remind us what was the
final goal here sorry I lost
to look upon me
yeah so the final goal
get back here
yeah we want to produce one Congo
instance to many instances of jungle
listing and that will help us to show a
conditional lower bound of Campbell
listing based on the exceptions
so this statement like is not and like
there is no mention of probability video
it's like a concrete statement yes yes
like even for randomized algorithms you
can solve the exact triangle being
faster than Q times
foreign
and finally we want to
um
in a match graph with om triangles is
hard so to do so we just need this Lemma
which says that if we can list all
triangles
yeah image graph with om triangles in
Tian time then we can list o1 triangles
for each arch in roughly uh
and across previously we showed harness
for the second problem here with this
Lemma it will imply the harness for the
first problem as well
can you show this Lemma
and it's a big sick proof idea of the
following
uh similar as before we can assume the
graph is chaptered by copying the
vertices three times
and then we only need also we can also
assume that we only need to list
triangles for edges between part A and
Part B
this is the cost between
we're copying the graph three times and
between each copy we're putting the a
copy of the original address
and
then for s from log n all the way down
to zero we create our subgraph GS by
keeping every vertex C in C with
probability 2 to an active s so
initially we keep every vertex with
probability one over n and then in each
iteration we will double this
probability
and in the final round we will keep
every vertex in C with probability one
so
in the final round overseas in the
policy will remain
then we list all changles in Gs
and if the number of triangles in JS is
not too much larger than M we can use an
algorithm that runs in TM time to solve
it
and after this iteration if we have
already listed enough address between
part A and B
then we will delete then we'll delete
this Edge in future iterations so we
have let's say enough edges enough
jungles for this Edge we do not need to
consider anymore
and the key property we need is that
each GS contains roughly n triangles
if GS contains more than M much more
than M triangles we cannot use uh an
algorithm for listing M triangles to to
solve it
and the correctness follows from the
last iteration right in the last
iteration we are keeping all the
vertices in C
so if at that point we haven't listed
enough triangles for some Hab that would
mean that um in the final iteration this
Hab will also be kept in the graph g0
so at that point we will just list all
the triangles the hab is contained in
so how do we show that GS contains of
the M triangles and that is because for
every Edge that is in much more than 2
to the S triangles it's likely that we
have listed enough triangles for it in
your previous situation
so suppose
some Edge a B is in 2 to the S Times log
M triangles
then in the previous iteration we are
keeping every vertex with probability 2
to the
um
probability 2 over 2 to the s
probability for one over two times two
to s
and at that point for each triangle
h a b is in we keep the third vertex C
with probability one over two times t to
the S so because a B is in mode like a b
is a more than two to the S Times log n
triangles we expect to see log n
triangles uh remaining that contains hap
and the log log n
is a greater than o1
so in this previous iteration we should
have listed enough triangle for hap with
high probability
and
therefore we can assume that in
iteration s
or edges that are in much more than two
to S triangles are deleted already and
for all other edges
we should have four other address that
has less than two to S Times log M
triangles in expectation we only to
expect to see log M triangles continue
it in in this iteration
so something over all these edges the
number of triangles overall in this
graph should be in the order of
M Times log n
which is still uh roughly um
reduction
this question is
so uh from you know the previous
tutorials there were strong
uh convincing evidence
right but those who are all not
randomized
see the evidence
the question is previous reductions are
not randomized
and so
okay so first of all
if your assumption is randomized and
your reduction depends to expands even
better
right and uh
yeah
so evidence previously processes that he
has more algorithms from himself much
faster than two to the end and that also
include randomized algorithms so
that people have tried to use
randomization in this in Design This
algorithms so if you assume that
you can also see upset in much faster
and two to the end
randomized time than like all this
evidence will still
this production
for this
um
all right
yeah I'm
yeah in general it's a very good
question with random words
it might be another problem all overhead
like like a order in or order and square
the overhead because she's like your
wife
but but on the other hand you know I
don't know about whether we can do it
for this reduction but there were
previous reductions like the trash per
reduction I mentioned before it was
originally randomized but now we have
deterministic reductions by Chan they're
very nice so it's very possible that
this can also
more work is needed
um
extensions to this triangle lifting
framework
so it's a it's natural to ask about
listing K clicks for K greater 3.
and in fact
um
Okay click we know that when there's
only one click we can list it in until
2K minus over three times and when the
number of Click clicks is maximum
to have an optimal algorithm
and in fact
foreign
there gks K minus one minus two over K
Square minus K minus two
as long as the number of K Clicks in the
graph is uh greater than or equal to GK
there's a matching up and lower bound
the upper bound assumes omegas 2 and the
lower bound assumes it's exact K click
hypothesis
and which is a natural generalization of
the exact triangle of hypothesis
this says that um in a given way to the
graph to find a k click whose graduates
sum up to zero requires roughly into the
K time
and assume this we can show that at
least in the tail they are matching
upper and lower bounds
in the middle we don't know the
um we don't have a matching upper load
on yet upper and lower bounds yet
this is also similar for the case of
triangle listing where we call in
patrascus results we know that listing M
triangles in our graph requires M24
sales term but we don't know about
listing one time going a graph
under the threesome hypothesis there are
some signal under a stronger hypothesis
so here it's a similar we know something
when T is large enough but not 20 is
somewhat smaller than threshold
and when the runtime is in terms of M
um the story is similar 20 is large
enough when it's larger than some M
times m to the power of h k we have
matching upper and lower bounds but when
until smaller we don't know the actual
answer
so uh in the Triangle place when you
show them you're very much
now when let's say you have a pickup
size four uh
[Music]
um in the test case you can still use
fasting small patient to solve four kick
but like as I mentioned earlier the
basic idea ideas to reduce
4K to try and go first foreign
Square
rectangular Matrix
before two videos on one Edge
and uh so far we have been expressed in
the running time in terms of l and m
which happens to be the number of one
clicks and two clicks in the graph
so it's also natural to ask okay we also
know the number of three clicks channels
in the graph which we know about Delta
and if we know that the number of
triangles is small can we design faster
algorithm to list keptics or
equivalently
so if we can do this then we can follow
this follow the following framework to
design faster opponents
initially when we came across we run
from triangle listing algorithm to list
all the triangles in the graph
and then once we have the list of all
the triangles we use an algorithm to
list K clicks based on the number of
triangles when given a list of triangles
and if this algorithm is efficient and
if the number of triangles in the graph
is small then potentially this can be
more efficient than just running these
algorithms that are in terms of mnm
directly
and more generally we can ask that uh
if we know the number of L Clicks in the
graph Delta L can we use it to find the
Or List K clicks for cake grater and
more efficiently in the graph
and I don't have time to cover this kind
of result but if you are interested you
can read this work which
considers exactly this type of problem
and and
[Applause]
questions
can you go back one slide I'd actually
have a question for Hunger movies so how
how would they instance for an instant
more space of
instance
work on drankers because now you know
the number of primes that need to be
reported what would um
the amount that we have for listing uh K
Clips basically is we can only look
after our certificates
to depend on the certificate which is
not a number of triangles which might be
something else
but we still have an additive factor in
the output yeah
so we
yes
this is for triangles
one of our customers
because you see the certificate of the
problem
which invisible
and
yeah
so it's adaptive to that instance
what is it
so does it solve question number three
that's my question
so Delta is out
and you're saying that certificate is
smaller than
I thought this is for today very very
click not just
because
depend on the number of candles
number
Maybe by my post a quick question along
this line as I said
um
parameters are very natural to databases
so in a relative ways when you build
let's say the edge relation of a graph
you would have kind of a histogram
information
but you will say that for this
collection of purposes
the maximum degree is such and such in
the next collection maximum degree is
such and such so it's um you know the
parameter like Delta may not be very
natural but
it's a different
type of parameter
from both vertex number 1000 to vertex
number two thousand
my maximum degree is this much
you can build them you can maintain
maintain them incrementally and the big
way to answer this question but under
that
anyways
good
so just